die innenstadt von regensburg einer von
vier sogenannten spielpunkten kinder und
jugendliche haben als kinder berater von
regensburg diese anlagen nicht nur
gefordert sondern zusammen mit der stadt
geplant und entworfen
ohne sie gäbe es diese mini spielplätze
nicht für die kinder in der stadt
einsetzen weil die erwachsenen wissen
haben eine andere sicht die erwachsenen
wissen dass jetzt wissen zwar einige
sachen von den kindern vielleicht und
wenn sich auch hin ganz ersetzen aber
eben nicht alles und das können sie auch
gar nicht wissen
also ich meine das ist ja nichts gegen
die erwachsenen regensburg ist eine
kinderfreundliche kommune ein programm
der unicef das kindern und jugendlichen
mehr mitsprache und eigene
entscheidungen ermöglicht auf augenhöhe
mit den stadtoberen zb unser
jugendbeirat die sind sehr aktiv
die haben immer wieder neue themen die
dann auch im stadtrat behandelt werden
müssen wenn es beschliessen also die
sind da sind sehr fordernd ein neues
selbstbewusstsein mit dem viele junge
menschen auftreten
auch der elterngeneration gegenüber sie
betrachten die politik mit skepsis sind
dafür selbst umso engagierter und
politischer wenn es gilt für die eigenen
belange wort zu ergreifen
für ihre zukunft das gilt vor allem für
die die gut informiert und interessiert
sind so die ergebnisse der neuen
shell-jugendstudie wir haben eine junge
generation heute das zeigt diese
achtzehnter shell jugendstudie der geht
es gut sie hat wunderbare
berufsperspektiven sie ist sehr hoch
gebildet und das ergebnis ist klar dass
machtpolitisch jedenfalls diejenigen die
gut abschneiden das sind heute menschen
sehr viele frauen darunter sich
belegungen frauen darunter die sind
einfach politisch interessiert und
wollen was verändern und haben ihre
themen wobei es laut studie vor allem im
osten auch etliche junge menschen gibt
die autoritär nationalistisch
eingestellt sind und in allen regionen
jugendliche die neutral oder ihr ohne
interessiert sind vielleicht auch weil
sie glauben dass man ihnen eh nicht
zuhört genau für die sind in köln heute
junge menschen zum ersten
internationalen gipfeltreffen
kinderfreundlicher kommunen zusammen
sie kritisieren dass städte ihnen viel
zu selten eine mitsprachemöglichkeit
geben auch wenn es um ihre belange geht
man sieht kinder und jugendliche oft
nicht auf einer augenhöhe also man nimmt
sie nicht ernst zum beispiel man
belächelt sie für irgendwas was sie
wollen und ich denke wenn man das
verändern würde würden sich auch mehr
jugendliche trauen es war nicht das
gefühl bekommen
man gehört irgendwie nicht dazu wir sind
ja eh nur kinder sondern dass wir auch
das gefühl haben wir haben eine stimme
wir können etwas verändern und das ist
auch wichtig dass wir was ändern weil
wir sind irgendwo ja auch die stimme
oder die seele der zukunft sage ich mal
selbstbewusst steht die jugend für ihre
überzeugungen ein politisch zu denken
sich einzumischen wenn nötig ist für
viele selbstverständlicher geworden
[Applaus]